for somebody like you even with this
nuclear deal that Obama was negotiating
with them I think John kery was leading
with $150
billion do you think that's going to
prevent Iran from you know creating you
know making advancements on nuclear
bombs well again I think the nature of
the regime is really why there's a lack
of trust because even if you sign the
best contract possible what guarantees
do you have that they'll be honoring
that contract it's a matter of trust TR
in that sense it's not the gun it's the
finger on the trigger issue why do you
negotiate with a
country that believes in death upon
America yet you want to release $150
billion as long as they commit to not
building nuclear not making advancements
on a nuclear bomb why do you trust that
regime that's exactly that's a
contradiction in that analysis that's
that's again pointing to what I'm saying
there's a flaw because you think that
these people have the
rationality of real politic in mind they
don't
they really don't so all that Stakes for
them is that if my enemy is weakening
I'm going to take advantage of it
America is the enemy America is the
great
Satan in the mindset of the regime not
the people the
regime when you see Iranian
students bypassing the American flag
that is at the entrance of every main
doors and you've seen the footage they
don't step on right that's a signal not
to the mulas beautiful thing when you
see that it's a signal to Mr Biden
that's
right and the American people that's
right that's right as we used to say
they're not practicing their linguistic
skills when they're holding signs in
English or in French when they're
protesting the regime it's a signal to
the outside world which is why if you
look at the Iranian people and where
they stand as opposed to this regime
that cannot possibly be trusted you
cannot eliminate what these the argument
of people like bi Netanyahu when it's
about an existential threat to Israel
because they know the nature of this
regime and in fact the Israelis know
that the Iranian people are so different
than this regime so do the Saudis in my
view I think some of the Europeans are
beginning to pick up on that I sure hope
that the American people already know
that because we have at least 1 and a
half million if not more Iranian uh
Americans of or people people of Iranian
origin Living in America and have a
chance to discover them and their
thoughts about their country and what
they represents in contrast to what this
regime
is what I wonder is I don't think so
many politicians today in Washington
really understand it whether they are on
the Congress side or in the executive
and that's a shame because this is the
moment in time that we need America to
be fully aligned to where the Iranian
people want to go when we know that
outside of this what China is trying to
do what Russia is trying to do yeah I
mean it's it's
U it's interesting by the way this is
this is it what you're talking about
they don't even want to step on the
Israel flag or the American flag when I
lived in Iran that that flag to us was
an idea I didn't link it to a face I
linked it to an idea of freedom of what
it meant the dream one day you know
you're watching Rocky 4 you know what
America would one day look like but by
the way so I'm I'm convinced they're
going to build a nuclear bomb whether
you like it or not they're going to hide
it from you they got plenty of desert
plenty of underground stuff that they
can do it without even you knowing about
it so you're better off when you're
negotiating with someone like that to
just say guys what are we doing they
they're going to build it anyways no
matter what you tell them not to do
they're going to build it
anyways